well Richard Isis the co-chairman of
leave means leave and Ally Renison is
head of Europe and trade policy at the
Institute of Directors so Richard mock
stone making reference there to the fact
that the UK's already lost a battle on
sequencing we can't talk about trade
negotiations until we've settled the
exit bill well in order to let's
remember the UK wanted to try and agree
this the position with UK citizens and
the youth citizens last summer and
actually was the EU that's being
delaying that that's not a concession at
all you know the issue of sufficient
progress that will be fudged the real
issue is that actually what needs to
happen is they need to accelerate these
talks to reduce the uncertainty for both
sides and it's interesting isn't it that
Michel Barnier also said that actually
no deal would not work for either side I
think that's absolutely critical what
what I was deeply disappointed about
yesterday was Philip Hammond undermining
the negotiating position of the United
Kingdom by suggesting that no deal would
be a very very bad outcome it wouldn't
it would be a fine as a base case we
revert to WTO if you go into a
negotiation not prepared to walk away
you end up like David Cameron with the
square root of nothing but that's the
point isn't it Ally I know countries are
may still threatened to walk away given
that when are effectively in a hung
parliament I think the threat will still
be there certainly at least implicitly
it was in her Lancaster House speech
it's what a lot of people paid attention
to but I think there'll be a lot more
attention and from the UK side including
potentially from the back benches the
Conservative Party focusing on what they
want out of a deal I'm a little bit less
sanguine about the idea of walking with
that we're way without a deal I don't
think a commercial boardroom is
necessarily the same thing as
negotiating between states and the
reason for that is that there are some
things that are known with respect to
the WTO so for example tariffs what
isn't covered is what service economy is
care about which is preferential
regulatory agreements what governs the
single market in effect the Irish border
you walk away without a deal you don't
really have a solution on the Irish
border that becomes a much harder bore
than it would be so I think that you
know what you're I think that actually
what he said is quite right actually is
that it's not a concession to have to be
talking about citizens rights first but
I think the II was also gotten itself
into a little bit of a pickle because it
says it wants to talk about the Irish
border as one of those three things
first how can you talk about the Irish
border without talking about trade
arrangements
look I think the Irish border is clearly
key everybody wants to sort that out but
there are there are many ways of
organizing out you know there's a soft
border between the United States and
Canada for example almost 2 billion
dollars a day flows over that border so
you know that actually is quite easy to
resolve what I'm really keen to see is
that actually they agree to accelerate
these talks what we can't have is this
sort of one week of negotiations a month
and then three weeks of posturing and
media noise and stuff you know and this
dragging on to March 19 in our view it
leave means leave they need to say if we
haven't reached a free trade deal by the
end of March next year then both sides
should accept they're not going to reach
that deal and start preparing for WTO
and the technical transitional
arrangements that's the way that you
accelerate certainty for everybody you
mentioned the border with Ireland just
now do you take any comfort from the
fact that the dup are now involved with
the gun because the DP of course say
they don't want the reintroduction of a
hard border with the Irish Republic I
think it certainly will mean that those
concerns are even more front and center
although when you read the DB's
manifesto it sort of effectively
replicates a lot of what the
Conservative Party set out in its
manifesto wanting to trade outside of
the customs union for example I think
that actually a lot of us are talking
past each other
we see potentially you know the end
destination of being out of the customs
union and out of the single market
potentially as a like reality the
question is is how fast do you get what
sort of process do you take to get there
because I think the issue here is that
you know as Richard mentioned yes there
there are solutions around the border
but the problem is is that when you to
look at the u.s. Canadian border they're
not moving back from something that's
effectively completely porous and
frictionless and that's where the scope
for disruption comes quite easily and
that's why the transition has to be
carefully managed which is not the same
thing as letting them go on ad infinitum
it's quite important to remember that
actually the EU has said that it wants a
time-limited transition so it's not as
if it you is trying to say to the UK
let's have an open-ended position where
you never actually leave you but
interesting it's organizations like the
CBI that are saying we need a long
transition we don't we need to
accelerate the process once you've
agreed heads of terms essentially just
like in business you put it in the hands
of lawyers and you accept that it
basically a deal is agreed in principle
everyone knows where they stand and that
must be accelerated - so do you think
there's a need for a transitional
agreement well I don't speak to the CBI
I represent the Institute of Directors
but obviously we see the need for
transition but I think that Richard is
right when he says that at a certain
point the entire free trade agreement
sort of details sewn up in one bag will
not be done if that you continues to
insist on this kind of separation
between the sequencing so they're going
to have to deem that sufficient progress
is made much earlier on potentially than
they thought but I think as long as the
transition is time-limited that's
something that we see from our members
point of view over 80% of them think
this is extremely important for their
business but it has to be an orderly
time-limited transition when this is the
risk Richard isn't it when Barney a has
more or less admitted that we may not
even start talking about trade until
October I mean that's completely
unsatisfactory isn't it it's completely
unacceptable it wouldn't happen in
business and this is actually you know
at the end of the day this is about the
economies of the eu27 and our economies
and so that must be accelerated
in my view and our view at lead means
leave you know David Davis he has got to
try and get the EU to agree to
accelerate this it's in everybody
interest the EU has significant other
issues out there it's in their interest
to accelerate this in the same way that
it's an ion trap
what about Ali's points that while WTO
terms may be perfectly acceptable for
manufacturers in services it's a whole
different ballgame well you say that but
actually there are no tariffs on
services and actually frankly most
businesses would much rather our own
sensible well regulated regulatory
environment than relying on the EU
regulations I think that is a key win
that's one of the great benefits of
brexit we can start to deregulate and
have sensible regulation I don't think
anyone's talking about tariffs on
services what I think businesses are
worried about is something for example
look at the chemicals sector we don't
have the chemicals regulator that is a
European dimension at the moment so we
need the time to make sure that we set
up our own so that when a product is
placed on the single market there's
something called reach which governs
it's a very sort of cumbersome bits of
regulation but it's what basically
governs harmonized trade in chemicals
you may not like it but the end of the
day trade is all about rules and it
makes it easier to have a preferential
agreement between the UK and the you to
facilitate that trade